another covet board we are keeping an
eye on is the one reflecting the impact
on the school district as of today they
are reporting
2657 cases since they began tracking
cases that's march of last year
christian is following the story forest
pushing health leaders about what it
really means for the kids and keeping
students and staff safe christian
well denise those numbers are concerning
but local and state health officials
tell me they are waiting for the
approval of the vaccine
for children until then they are getting
ready and laying out the groundwork
now during today's covet update we were
told that the big focus
is to keep moving forward on the youth
population and keeping them
in school health leaders are waiting for
a vaccine approval for children
which is still in the trial stage so
they can get the help to minimize the
spread in school
now they say the cdc recently received
an award which means
more funding for nevada 90 million
dollars will be allocated to the state
for educational efforts we're meeting
with the department of ed and looking at
how we're gonna
implement that it's a really strong
testing program
case investigation and contact tracing
program so again our federal partners
are really
uh focused on youth and keeping kids in
school so we're excited about that
well as we mentioned before ccsd is
reporting more than 2 600
cases total since march of last year 10
new cases
were reported today and according to
their dashboard both staff and students
have reached over 1100
positive cases now again the vaccination
push for the youth population will begin
when a vaccine for that group is
approved christian casadas 8 news now